des milliers d'enfants avant reprendre
le chemin de l'école au cours des
prochains jours et pour signer la fin
des vacances à on a voulu a peu parlé
des outils qui existent pour aider les
élèves dans leur réussite scolaire des
outils qui sont autant pour les élèves
que pour leurs parents vous allez voir à
mes côtés le porte parole de l'organisme
allô prof marc antoine tanguay bonjour
monsieur tanguay on joue libéré la
rentrée d'après noël c'est peut-être pas
la rentrée scolaire de septembre mais
quand même c'est stressant pour bien des
élèves oui quand même quand même c'est
pas la même fébrilité qu'en septembre
c'est vrai mais dans le fond la période
des fêtes c'est le temps aussi de faire
un peu le point sur les premiers mois de
l'année puis des fois de se donner
quelques résolutions pour la suite afin
que le reste de l'année scolaire se
passe bien beau quelle résolution
les élèves et les parents devraient
prendre mais en fait c'est selon chacun
évidemment tout le monde n'a pas les
mêmes défis mais de façon générale quand
on discute avec les élèves
l'organisation de l'étude en général
c'est c'est souvent le défi le plus
important celui qui revient même chez
des élèves qui performent beaucoup qui
réussissent bien à l'école souvent
inutilisables
si je m'organise un petit peu mieux ce
serait peut-être plus facile alors on
pense par exemple à la période des
devoirs les des trucs pour pour que ça
se passe bien que ce soit peut-être plus
fluide plus harmonieux consommer peu
plus motivés à faire les devoirs des
fois dans le quotidien on veut fuir la
routine mais dans le cas des devoirs à
être routinier avec une heure précise
pour faire allez devoir chaque soir
c'est une bonne idée
où exactement parce qu'en plus c'est que
ça aide aussi l'enfant a développé une
bonne organisation de son étude en
général donc non seulement il ya les
devoirs qui vont être plus facile à
réaliser si on a une bonne routine parce
que ça devient comme naturel au quai à
telle heure je me mets dans mes devoirs
pendant 30 ans
mais en plus on y va répercuter ce après
vers son étude en vue des examens et le
ça devient encore plus important qu'ils
ont raison même si c'est pas toujours
facile à faire quand on est aux études
pas étudié la dernière minute pour un
examen est toujours une bonne idée
oui mais bon je pense ça reste une
résolution affaires à faire
et pourtant on le sait on étudie
beaucoup mieux à coups de 15 20 minutes
que plusieurs heures la veille d'un
examen
en plus ça laisse le temps de réagir si
on n'a pas très bien compris sur le site
web d'allô prof vous allez voir derrière
l'adresse apparaître à l'écran manama il
ya des nouveautés cette année pour les
gens oui toujours des nouveautés
puis dans le fond ça c'est une haute
résolution qu'on pourrait prendre mais
normalement on devrait avoir du plaisir
et étudier aller à l'école donc si un
jeune sans qui a pas tant de plaisir que
ça à l'école
il devrait voir qu'est ce qui peut faire
pour en avoir et ça ça va le motiver
davantage donc sur allô prof nos
nouveautés cet automne c'est surtout des
jeux des applications pour pratiquer les
choses qui sont des fois un peu plus
laborieuse comme la conjugaison des
verbes la conjugaison des verbes
irréguliers en anglais les mots de
vocabulaire de l'année c'est un petit
jeu comme ça exactement
il s'est beaucoup plus intéressant et
stimulant de le faire de cette façon là
et donc on va on y passe plus
spontanément du temps que ça permet de
partager le temps écran aussi entre ce
qui est vraiment du loisir purée ce qui
est utile donc pour les parents qui
veulent négocier le temps écran avec
leurs enfants dès fois leur dire que je
peux rester sur ton exactement pour
apprendre et pas juste pour se divertir
on a produit des conseils également pour
les apparents parce qu'elle au prof a
lancé une plate-forme allô prof parents
il ya quoi 1 environ
oui il ya un as de la fin novembre de
l'année pacifiquement quel constat fait
on ben en fait ça se passe super bien
l'on constate qu'on a
soixante mille par an par mois qui
viennent consulter les différents
contenus sur la plateforme internet ils
peuvent aussi communiquer avec eux des
professionnels comme nous ont coupé la
drogue ou des enseignants pour poser
leurs questions par téléphone ou par
messenger
donc il y avait vraiment un besoin tout
à fait quel genre de question des prêts
par an rose c'est quoi la principale
problématique avec les parents ont
souvent problématiques d'organisation
mais une motivation aussi comment je
fais pour aider mon enfant à 6 m dans
les devoirs à rester motivé à les faire
et c'est là où on peut intervenir en
leur donnant toutes sortes de trucs
d'outils je parlais des des jeux par
exemple sont une façon de se motiver
mais des fois aussi quand on parle de
routine c'est tout simple on peut
télécharger on ne se fait insulter sur
notre plate forme on peut télécharger un
petit horaires et on est inscrit là
dedans c'est l'enfant qui est appelée
inscrits en thèse qui veut faire c'est
de voir où ils veulent et faire dans
quelles conditions avec quels mots
et que par exemple donc quand on donne
le choix aux enfants des fois c'est plus
motivant aussi de s'y mettre parce
qu'ils ont l'impression que ça vient
d'eux parce que les parents s'y retrouve
facilement dans l'éducation parce que
bon au fil des réformes
les parents ont pas appris
nécessairement de la même façon que la
des façons dont on enseigne à leurs
enfants ça doivent faire partie des
questions qui arrive régulièrement
très régulièrement mais c'est normal
l'éducation évolué évidemment faux pas
en reste et est ce qu on apprenait et
puis la manière d'enseigner 10 à 20 ans
si on trouve des meilleures techniques
aujourd'hui mais en même temps les
parents ont pas non plus à être des
enseignants c'est pas ça leur rôle alors
ils ont un rôle d'encadrement de
motivation mais quand viennent les
questions techniques en jeu quand ils
savent plus vraiment comment expliquer
quelque chose à ce moment là où ils
peuvent se tourner vers allô prof par
exemple et demander à nos enseignants
comment ça se fait aujourd'hui où aller
sur le site pour voir plus la méthode
d'autrefois la méthode d'aujourd'hui
faire le pont qui restait actif dans les
devoirs de leurs enfin bon il ya un loup
parents allô prof internement on vise
quelle clientèle bon bien sûr primaire
secondaire on arrête sans sa conversion
oui c'est tout le primaire ou secondaire
on s'adresse aussi aux adultes qui est
des adultes qui ont pas nécessairement
leur diplôme d'études secondaires en
poche ils retournent aux études alors on
répond aussi à leurs questions c'est
toujours gratuit et c'est comme jeter
tous les niveaux et oui pas aller aux
profs et allô prof parents deux outils
très utiles pour ce retour à l'école à
compter des prochains jours
merci beaucoup monsieur tanguay pour
cette cette entrevue ce matin est
excellente année 2010 9
merci très belle année scolaire à tous
les élèves et alors